soan baba aïssa merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on le
disait large majorité de oui pour la
réforme constitutionnelle mais une
abstention record
quel bilan vous pouvez faire de ce
scrutin historique
bah pour moi d'abord je dirais que c'est
la victoire du chirac c'est la victoire
de la révolution du sourire et ce n'est
certainement pas la victoire de cette
région delà de la région algéroise et
ceux de ce système politique
les algériens et les algériennes ont
vraiment dit que il confirme que il
rejette ce pouvoir politique et que de
toute façon un seul projet de 2,2
constitution ne ne les concerne pas
parce que de toute façon il n'est pas
l'émanation de la souveraineté nationale
il n'a pas été dans le processus d'une
constituant donc il y à vraiment
aujourd'hui une rupture inéluctable
entre le peuple algérien et cette caste
politique et d'ailleurs on le voit bien
même au niveau de la participation
eux qui avaient pour habitude
d'organiser la fraude d'avoir une
clientèle qui étaient là dans le milieu
militaire de la police des petits
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui même cette
clientèle là ils n'ont pas su la
rassembler elle n'a pas répondu présent
et le véritable taux de participation il
est 2 1% c'est ça la réalité ils n'ont
pas réussi à mobiliser un tiers de leur
clientèle habituelle et donc on voit
bien que ce système politique c'est free
que la bête est blessée et tu nous avons
un résultat qui est fabriqué pour faire
croire à l'opinion internationale qui
l'a légitimé
il n'y a aucune légitimité à ce pouvoir
politique
le peuple algérien le rejet et on l'a vu
si il y à eut un instrumental isation du
cobp ils disent même empêché les marches
le peuple a exprimé aujourd'hui
southwell un véritable changement est
d'arriver à l'auto détermination et même
je dirais gérer plus noir c'est que même
la révolution du sourire nous amène vers
une véritable rupture car même le
populisme des islamistes n'a pas réussi
à avoir un poids significatif avec son
nom à ce qui a l'habitude on le sait il
est toujours du côté de la région sadji
roises il est toujours là pour tenter 2
de se placer de trouver une légitimité
et ben non c'est un véritable échec de
ce référendum
c'est un désaveu de ce pouvoir et sa
roue solid la dure et dell dans cette
revendication du peuple algérien à après
ce désaveu alors après ce désaveu
justement quel avenir voyez-vous pour
pour l'algérie est ce qu'il y a des des
figures qui se démarquent comment est-ce
que ça va pouvoir maintenant avancer
lorsque j'adore toujours c'est qu'on
nous demande toujours est ce qu'il ya
des figures qui se débat je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le camp démocratique a
gagné parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment ancrée maintenant dans la
société algérienne
cette société algérienne élevé à changer
elle veut un autre processus elles ne
mentent demande pas aujourd'hui à avoir
des figures qui est mal elle demande une
transition démocratique avec un
processus de constituants c'est ça va
venir
et aujourd'hui il va falloir que ce
pouvoir qui en place en prennent
conscience et que là que le camp
démocratique ou presque aujourd'hui si
lui qui domine parce que la population
algérienne
elle veut ce changement là elle ne veut
plus de ce système ou d'éthique s'est il
est fini il est
désaveu total il m'avait déjà pas de
légitimité à l'issue des élections du 12
décembre 2019 et là le désaveu passe à
ce référendum
ils ont bu la plébiscitent ils ne l'ont
pas eue et l'avenir est entre les mains
du camp démocrate et ils coûtent ils en
prennent conscience
merci beaucoup soa de baba aïssa d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes vice présidente de l'alliance
des démocrates de la diaspora algérienne